Nick Jonas drops a new song about love
and we think it's about fiancee Priyanka
Chopra the two got engaged last month
after about two months of dating and we
know Priyanka loves a romantic gesture
I am very romantic at heart and I think
if you care about somebody there's
nothing wrong in making someone feel as
special as you feel like they are in
your heart it doesn't have to be
expensive it doesn't have to be
something like you know you spend a lot
of money on but as long as you're
thoughtful I think it's really sweet
there's nothing sweeter than serenading
your love publicly which is something
Nick told us he wanted to work on I have
regrets about not being open with
relationships in the past you know
that's that's the thing that makes it
actually more challenging is on many
levels you end up trying to hide the
relationship or do things to try to keep
it private but it actually just puts
more stress in the relationship so is
right now a public romantic gesture for
his love decide for yourself
[Music]